in 2017 when i met a soft
French girlfriend in a
youth hostel in prague i
would never have imagined that french
would have become an important part
of my life
hello i am in the case of lucas
l'imperial at dot com is today  today
I'm going to tell you about how I
learned the French language and the
lesson I learned on the way I'm
sure of it now but I did
n't know 20 years ago when I started to
learn French  olivier what
matters most is not
what you do in class but what
you do outside of class and that
's exactly what I
started doing two years after starting the
French with in high school i.e. I
watched French television all the time
because I discovered
that I could watch France 2 and not
only French then speak but
also I could watch all that
with subtitles page 8 quickly  quickly I
still remember  very good and that's going
to get a lot of excitement and i
started watching a series a
show a documentary a movie
every night taking notes because
i could actually look at the words i was
listening to it completely  changed
my approach my perspective in general
and so if you learn a language
at school we in a class in a
language in a in a language school
you have to know that what you
do outside of class counts 90%  of
your learning process after
what you do at school is
literally the icing on the cake
trying to rise trying
to get tense french is a
language where nothing is as it seems  in
fact the spoken language is very
different from the written language and that is
why dictation is considered a
mandatory and essential tool
for the good command of French
I actually remember very well when
I went to high school precisely there  had
in  france is between us who had
moved with his family here in italy
they spoke perfect french
but he really had trouble writing
it it's very important to know that in
general when you learn a language you
have to take it organically  or
overall mysticism, that is to say learning
to speak of course but also learning to
write to read all the skills that
you develop they will they will
integrate over time it is very
important not to forget that and to
treat  every aspect of the language
every day or even every week
as I said at the beginning of the video
when I met my girlfriend I
never imagined that French would
become an important part of my head
I never imagined that I  would have
moved to france it changed and
enriched my perspective
on language learning in general
because when i lived in france
i discovered that speaking a language
is also about knowing a culture and
jules e  st vu me yes of course I knew
before but after seeing it with your
own eyes living it every day
it's something a little different for
example the moment of the galette des rois
the gestures that the point that the French
they make the  cultural references the
things you can do in one country
and it's a little weird to do in
another than cutting the salad in italy
it's totally normal in france a little
less and so that gave me the  a
very important perspective on
what it means to learn a language
I always say that learning a
language you can do it well you can you
can do it in any country you want but
speak almost like a native if you want to
do that  it's important to live the
language and live in a country it will
give you a global perspective on the
language because a language is also
the culture and the culture is also the
language you must never forget that we
came to the end of the video
so it's for re  surrender it is very
important first two to take orders
from the class and 90% of the
learning process
it is very important to learn a
language holistically because it is
like a living organism and third
point it's important if you want to speak
almost like a native to live in a
country because you'll see how
people really live their language
if you want to know more you can
click on the link in the
description box I wrote  an article in
English on the wonderful
French language that you can also listen to in
English and
I'm waiting for you on my site on my
blog thank you for my side and I hope
to see you soon here on youtube
[Music]